scientists across the world are now
trying to work out the threat from
omicron this is what we're up against
the first 3d map of all the mutations in
the protein spike that covers the
surface of the virus side by side with
our current adversary delta
in red are the areas most heavily
mutated when compared with the original
virus the one from wuhan and there are
many more in omicron that constellation
of mutations is important because it was
the original virus that the vaccine was
designed to tackle so on paper
it doesn't look good but it's real world
evidence that really counts there are
three key questions that need rapid
answers how transmissible is it to take
over from delta is a dominant strain it
will have to spread more quickly is it
more virulent if it causes more severe
disease it would increase
hospitalizations and deaths but there
are other variants that cause milder
symptoms so which is it
is there immune escape all those
mutations are likely to reduce the
effectiveness of the antibodies
generated by the vaccine or previous
infection but t cells are less affected
by mutations so does that mean we'll
still have enough immunity to fight off
the new variant
now who is doing what well labs
including important down in the uk will
be testing blood taken from people
who've recovered from covid against the
new variant that will give the first
clues on whether our antibodies are good
enough to kill the virus
vaccine manufacturers will be doing
their own tests to see whether they can
still neutralize the variant or whether
they need to redesign the jab
and most importantly of all there will
also be epidemiological studies most
likely in south africa because it's got
the most cases they will tell us how
well the current vaccines actually
reduce the risks of serious disease now
we should get the first results from the
lab tests in the next couple of weeks
the clinical studies will take a bit
longer perhaps early in the new year
then we'll properly understand the
threat from omicron